قال وزير خارجيه مالي عبد الله بين بلاده
لا تعترض على قرار الاتحاد الافريقي الخاص
بتعليق عضويتها بمؤسسات الاتحاد لحين عوده
الحكم الديمقراطي
ري خارجيه مالي في جزء من مهمه المشتركه
تشمل بوركينا
اننا لا نعترض على تعليق عضويتنا في
الاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه اكواس لانه ليس
اجراءا عقابيا بل هو فرصه لاعاده الالتزام
بعوده النظام الدستوري المشكله الرئيسيه
التي نواجهها هي انعدام الامن الذي تسبب
في خساره الحكومه لجزء كبير من اراضيها
نريد ان نشارك في مناقشه قضايا الامنيه
والانسانيه كيف يمكنك مناقشه محاربه
الارهاب في منطقه الساحل ولا يوجد ممثلون
من دولنا الثلاث كل هذه اسئله نريدهم حقا
ان يعيدوا التفكير فيها
وعن انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه من مالي
والوجود الروسي في بلاده قال وزير خارجيه
مالي عبد الله ديوب قال للجزيره لبلاده
حريه اختيار شركائها الخارجيين مشيرا في
حديثه للجزيره الى ان اي شركاء على اي
شركاء احترام صياده مالي وخياراتها
الاستراتيجيه
الامر بسيط بالنسبه لنا بحسب ما قال رئيس
مالي لدينا ثلاث قواعد ذهبيه لتفاعلنا مع
المجتمع الدولي اولا احترام سيادتنا
واحترام خيارنا الاستراتيجي الذي تقوم به
حكومتنا في اختيار الشركاء والثالث هو
التاكد من مراعاه المصالح الحيويه لمال في
جميع عمليات صنع القرار